with the fence project well underway
Andy turns his attention to another
critical task for their harvest living
out here we try and utilize all the
resources that we have available to us
when we're clearing land whether it be
for new building projects gardens or
fire breaks I try and utilize those
trees as much as I can
the trees are chipped up and we turn
that into compost we don't have great
soil right around here it's very acidic
soil so composting is really important
to us everything that I do out here has
multi-purpose so by having the ability
to plan ahead I'm able to get a lot more
out of the limited resources that I have
here there are very specific things that
you have to do during certain times of
the year we have four and a half months
to grow a year's worth of food and so
time becomes critical to us
son of a [ __ ] it's not gonna work this
is just too wide
willows aren't long enough throat is
facing I had that concern when we first
started weaving them I made a mistake I
was thinking the Willows are longer and
they weren't so I don't have willows
long enough to support this widest pants
no I've got to go
just undo everything that I've done if
you were to take this and put this in
between vertically yeah set up and it
wouldn't even have to go in that far
because it's gonna hold itself in there
I know that and I'm just trying to
suggest things to you here hi I'm now
rust rated I'm frustrated and I know
that part I know how to do this but I'm
just saying I just screwed up with this
no because it's not a screw up it's just
an ax modification that's how so hand me
another one there and we'll just see how
this works and he feels that my original
design is not good enough so I'll change
that it's annoying I just had a problem
and I never had a chance to be able to
fix it on my own
he takes control of everything I mean
just pisses me off